during the course of filming lifeboat
which you know covered rescue operations
in the mediterranean off the coast of
libya
in the first three days
of that
rescue mission
um
you know we came upon over 3 000 people
asylum seekers floating in flimsy rafts
in the water
and we were on the zodiacs and um we
were filming and
within the first couple hours you know
we would come up to
these
rafts and these boats that were in
really dire shape
and people would be pushed off and
people would jump off and people would
fall into the water
and
some of them couldn't swim
and so we found ourselves in this moment
where we had a choice we could film
someone drown in front of us
or we could put our cameras down and
pull them out of the water
and so that's what we did
we put our cameras in the
bottom of the zodiac and just started
pulling people out of the water
and um
you know if i was wise men right
according to his
paradigm then we should have just filmed
and
um i didn't anticipate that moment
beforehand
i had no sort of foreknowledge that i
was going to find myself faced with that
dilemma of the moment as a documentarian
but there was no question in my mind
that i had to put my camera down and
pull that fellow human being out of the
water and i don't regret it at all so
i've come to a different place i've
evolved to what i believe for the kind
of film that i do
is more appropriate right like
i can go to sleep at night
knowing that
regardless of how the film would have
been different if i hadn't made that
choice
i made the right choice as a human being
so i i think of it as being a human
being first in a filmmaker second in
moments like that
that's beautifully beautifully put but i
also think like
you could be a human being in small ways
too
like silly ways and put a little bit of
yourself in
in documentaries i i tend to see that as
really beautiful
like when like the meta piece of it like
like yeah just just put yourself into
the
into the movie a little bit because uh
like break that
third fourth whatever the wall is
is
realize that there's a human behind the
camera too for some reason me as a fan
as a viewer
that's enjoyable too i think there's a
real authenticity there
behind the straw especially with these
hard stories that you're doing that
there's a human being struggling to
like uh
observing the suffering
and having to
bear the burden
that this kind of suffering exists in
the world and you're behind that camera
living that struggle
and there's small ways to show yourself
in that way
as you know i i don't do that in a big
way but you know i actually there are
subtle moments where i allow
that presence to live just for a second
like like i hate belly button docs
that's what i call them i don't know
what's about the belly button doc is
navel gazing right where
there's a sort of a narcissistic
filmmaking where someone just
studies their own place in the world
right i i think i see yeah yeah i think
my
you know or
i i'm more concerned with
how i can intervene
right yeah um well you're trying to
really deeply empathize
yeah so like if you emphasize
i don't want to center myself in these
stories it's not about me right i am so
unimportant
what is important is what's happening
what's unfolding in the world that we
need to act upon and right and i think
it's selfish and narcissistic
to to you know push myself into these
stories unnecessarily now that said i
think there is some small value in what
you're saying just to remind viewers
that there's obviously a filmmaker at
play so sometimes the way that i do that
is just like through a question on
camera i'd allow the audio to live
of a question or during a conversation
i'm having with someone so they can they
can just hear how it's posed for example
right and to me that's enough
yeah i i do like moments
when people
recognize that you exist they they look
at the filmmaker past the camera
and that yes you ask the question in the
interview or something like that and
they respond to that yeah uh like they
respond to this like new perturbation
into their reality that was created by
this other human yeah and i especially
like when those questions or those
perturbations are like a little bit
absurd and like add something very novel
to their situation and that novelty
reveals something about them
so as opposed to capturing
the day-to-day reality of their life you
do that plus
the perturbations of like something
novel yeah that and but of course
there's there's there's all kinds of
ways to do this let me um
what was number five by the way only i
only gave you four you get you just
stay at four th there's a short doc i
like i mentioned they're called the
toxic pigs of fukushima
i know i know i apologize
it's dark it's a great title though
right a great title it's a great title
it's it's no one's seen it but it's
great
it's it says what it sounds like yeah
yeah it's exactly what it sounds like
but really brilliantly executed
well let me ask you about lifeboat
because it's extremely
i don't
um
it's a really moving um
idea just just the fact that this exists
in the world that there's uh as a
metaphor as a reality
that there is
a set of people trying to flee
desperately is the desperation of it
and now with his refugees the
desperation of that of of trying to
escape
towards a world that
full of mystery uncertainty uh doubt
could be hopeless at times and you're
willing to do a lot
for your own survival for the survival
of your family and all those kinds of
things that's kind of the the human
spirit and you just capture it
um
in lifeboat can you tell me
the story behind this film as you
started to already tell
can you tell me what is it about
so lifeboat um
[Music]
really seeks to
sort of
lift up and showcase
the asylum seeker
crisis
in the mediterranean when it was at its
height um
in 2016.
and um it came to be
for many reasons but but one of those
reasons is is
colleagues in the ngo community really
shared with me that
when the borders between greece and
turkey were shut down that the
the flow of syrian asylum seekers that
was initially going across from turkey
to greece
was going to shift westward across the
mediterranean so i started to research
that and discovered that was exactly the
case
and then further
stumbled upon the fact that um
nation states hadn't really stepped up
to address it and that there were
hundreds of asylum seekers often
drowning in these flimsy crafts that
were pushed off from the shores of libya
because the eu
wasn't
doing its duty
to patrol those waters from a
humanitarian standpoint and so
the net result of that was that this
whole sort of like humanitarian
community sprung up
and it was civil society based that that
tried to meet the needs of those asylum
seekers to to just ensure that fellow
human beings weren't drowning
simply put and one of those was this
small little ngo called sea watch which
when they discovered what was happening
just cobbled together a coalition of
volunteers
bought a research vessel
retrofitted it and
motored down off the coast of libya to
start pulling people out of the water
and again i found that inspiring right i
found that inspiring that this group of
volunteers
was doing something that our leaders
wouldn't
right and it was something as basic and
simple as saving human beings
um
and um i thought there was an inspiring
story there and as it turned out there
was
have you ever saved someone's life
as as a as part of making
these documentaries directly and
directly i think you probably have
countless lives but directly were you
put in that position i i don't i don't i
don't wanna
i mean i certainly poured people out the
water who couldn't swim
i did that
and that's again speaking to the basic
humanity put down the camera and help
yeah
uh so this is people coming from libya
yeah trying to make it across the
mediterranean sea
on a crappy tiny boat
from a filmmaker perspective how do you
film that was there decisions
to capture the desperation well we were
you know
we were
going back to this idea of access and
how that's so fundamental to my approach
um
you know we we were bound by the
strictures of the rescue operation on
this sea watch vessel which was 30
meters long and we were two of a crew of
15
right so we had to multitask all the
time because the only reason we were on
that boat was
by agreeing that
if needed we would do whatever necessary
right
to
um to help
right and so it's very active on
multiple levels and and um
we were making decisions each and every
day that were
not only filmmaking and creative
decisions but also just
decisions about
how
how to
live that duality
right of being a humanitarian and a
filmmaker simultaneously
and
the greatest example i can share
of that was
with my director photography in that
project kenny allen he um
kenny's a big guy it's like
he's got like arms like tree trunks and
um
and he because he was so physically able
and strong
the head of mission um
really tasked him to be on the zodiac to
pull people out of the water because he
could literally with one arm reach down
and just oftentimes pull someone out
right
um whereas usually you would take two or
three people for it and so when we were
at the height of triage and there were
people in the water all over and rafts
were sinking um kenny was out pulling
people out of the water and this went on
for like 24 hours right and at the end
of that first day i remember like
looking over on the deck
and seeing kenny like help people up
from the ladders to walk them back right
and his camera was nowhere to be seen
yeah right and so i walked over to him
and i just grabbed him by the shoulders
and said kenny
where is your camera
and he didn't know he had no idea where
his camera was right and so i just said
kenny
we're here to do what you're doing
but we're also here to film it right to
make sure that we document what is
unfolding in front of us so we have a
record of it right so we can bring it to
a larger audience so you need to go find
your camera so we can also document it
yeah and that kind of pulled him out and
he went and got his camera and started
filming again but but that gives you a
sense of sort of this world that we had
to live in in order to get the story
done but i think
to be a great director of photography to
be a great director you have to lose
yourself like that
in the story too
but usually with a camera in your hand
right but sometimes you forget the
camera i mean like th there's a
i feel like
if you're obsessed with the camera too
much
you can lose the humanity of it you get
obsessed with the film and the story can
become clinical yes yeah absolutely and
it's it's you know i yeah absolutely and
and we don't want to become we i don't
want to become clinical in my films
certainly
you